Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Subnautica
Now, I know it's been a long time since I played this,
and ADMITTEDLY, on the last episode that I did,
I didn't even know if I would be playing it again,
because it left on kind of a final note,
getting to the deepest point that was currently in the game.
Now, this is a brand new game that I'm starting,
and I don't intend to skip forward in it,
because it's been about 5 months
th-since I last played.
And what is really interesting about the game,
is that it's been updated a lot, as was expected through the procedural
updating and what-not, ah, every few months.
There is a lot new creatures, a lot new craftables,
and a lot new things like that. But more importantly
than any of that is, I wanna play this game in terms of
feeling and exploring the game again.
When I was doing those episodes before,
it-uh felt like I was showcasing the developer updates,
which is kinda not what the game is about,
and it's not kinda what I wanted to do for videos.
So, when I was doing the previous videos, and some of
you guys noticed this, it was like
the means to the end, the ends to the mean, whatever the phrase is
I don't even know, I'm not smart enough to know about that.
But it was like, I was doing things
specifically only to do a specific other thing,
without enjoying what Subnautica was, the ocean that
you're in. The WONDERFUL environments,
the beautiful, horrific creatures,
and there are more. The-
*Inhales*
The Reaper Leviathan actually is in the game now,
and can shoot FIREBALLS, as far as I know,
but I have intentionally
NOT looked into the updates.
The many, many updates that there have been,
I have not looked into them, BECAUSE
I wanna explore it,
I wanna find it, I wanna see it all,
see everything about it, I wanna know everything about it
by finding it without having it handed to me.
You know what I mean? I want this to be..
exploration for US,
and not exploration for the game.
Or whatever it is- I'm trying to say something profound there,
and it's not entirely working out,
but anyway... LET'S BLAST OFF!
The only survivor... A lonely solitude incoming!
And also, they fixed some things about this intro sequence,
but I don't think they changed very much,
uh, since the last time I showed it to you guys,
other than the fact that it's super cool,
and we still don't know what blew up the ship.
And that is a mystery, like, "What caused this ship
to blow up?"
And...
Was it right it right or wrong in thi-
Ah, shit, my face-
Was it right or wrong in thinking that,
there was another ship that came to this planet
before we did? --Like-- We're obviously..
either a scientific exploration or-
or a colonization thing. Like, that's why we're here.
But,
I believe there was some sort of information that
there was another ship before us.
So anyway, I gotta take care of this bullshit-
Haaa-booshki!!!! Oh YES...
Alright, we're good here, everybody good?
Everybody good?
Okay, so, now that we're actually in the game,
I wanna make a few promises to you guys
that I'm legitimately gonna keep this time.
NUMBER ONE!
I'm never gonna cheat again.
Not ONCE.
Not NEVER.
Not one time EVER,
am I gonna cheat again, because
that ruins the experience of the game.
The other thing about this is:
I.. am alone.
I will have no outside help,
I'll have no information, other than the
information you guys give me because
I'm still gonna be reading you guy's comments in between each episode.
But, in the mean time, I won't be able to put names on lockers-
-until I'm able to build friggin' lockers.
But they've done a lotta more things--
--A lotta more, A LOTTA more. ;)
They've done a lot more to improve the
beginning experience of the game,
and, by "improve", I mean, "make *Deep voice* HARDER."
As some of you know, it was a bit easy to get started in the game.
You take 4 titanium, and then do
your dang ol' thing, and then
build a base, and then your outta here.
But,
as far as I know, we're gonna be using this life pod for a good, long time,
so we better get used to this Bad Boy over there,
and all the wondrous joys that it brings.
So, we're here, and apparently, I can
get lead out of these things now,
but I'm just gonna be gathering
resources for a bit to get...started...
Okay, either I have not payed
attention to the ocean in a while,
or... they've added some new sh- Ah.. shit, there we go.
(Mining noises)
(Animal noises)
Well, YOU guys are lot more noisy than you used to be-
Hey, can I poke you in your big bu--
--Ulgh...
Why do you sound like you're laughing?!
That's not okay! I'm new to this world!
Well, I mean, I'm not new, but I'm
starting out like a fresh baby--
Ugh, gawdammit, just let me get the shit
(Makes random picking noises)
Augh!!!
That's the fuckin' creepiest thing I've ever heard
in my gawddamn life!!
(Strange laughter-like noises)
WHY!!!!!????
WHY WAS THAT A NECESSITY??!!
Okay, anyway, I need-- What are you-- Oh, I know what you are, I think.
*Interface voice* New creature discovered
Oh COOL! They got a better interface for it.
That's nice.
I'm gonna get these Garyfish,
and I'm gonna cook 'em up.
Gonna cook 'em all up.
Hey. You. Air sack.
Come here, you. Don't you run away.
Oooh, Bladderfish! Niice!
Gahd, you know, this is what I- This is what I missed about the game.
Th-The experience of just wandering around the ocean,
holding on to GARY as tight as I can,
so he doesn't get away from me,
then just kinda, like, experiencing the
wonders of this weird ocean,
and then venturing out from the safety of my
encampment to-- Ahh! I almost had you!
Get stuck, get stuck-- YEAH!
Get stuck, get stuck, get stuck, get stuck--
My advantage is that you're dumb--
What I need right now,
is food in mah BELLY.
I'm gonna do exactly that.
LaBooShki... (laser noise)
Now I'm gonna cook you Gary...
Sorry, Gary.
I'm gonna keep this one Gary in my hand.
I don't wanna-- I don't wanna mess with this Gary,
this Gary is my, kinda, favorite Gary.
Ha-Bleurgh.. Ha-Bloo.. Ha-Bleurgh..
Okay, I'm good,
the rest of you bladderfish get to survive
for just a little bit longer, because
I need to make shit before I can kill you.
Oh my gahd, they actually have textures for things!
It has been a long time since I played, 'cause
they fixed up a lot of stuff.
I'm gonna make some batteries-- I don't know why,
but I'm gonna do that.
I need a scanner, I believe.
Okay, scanner.
And the one thing that I'm definitely gonna do,
is I'm gonna go out at night, which is
my least favorite thing to do.
And you guys' favorite thing to do, because you get to watch me be a little screamy bitch!
But this time, I'm gonna make a flashlight,
because I don't actually have that yet.
It's so GOOD to be starting back from the beginning,
but also, so terrifying. I'm not-
-I'm not as, like, you know,
well-prepared as I used to be, in terms of
What I'm doin' here, and I don't exactly KNOW
what I'm doin' here.
I'm probably gonna die in a lot of horrible ways,
but- You know what? That's oka--
--Oh gahd, it's getting dark already.
Okay, so, besides that, we're gonna try to do
what we need to do here--
Which is a whole lot of "I Don't Know"...
(More strange laughter-like noises)
WHYYYY!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
That is the creepiest sh*t!
Gahd, if I came out here at night and I heard laughing,
I'd poop mah pants.....
I don't think I got a suit that can recycle my shiet.
Oh boy...... Oh Boy.......OH BOY, I feel helpless..
Ah, I feel so helpless...
I think what it is, it's like the, uh-- It's the comparison
between this and a horror game-- not exactly-- but
in a horror game, you know
how you don't have weapons, and that's kind of
best situation because you're totally helpless?
It's THAT feeling of isolation and helplessness.
Ohhh, music.....
Hello...
Aah
Oh my gahd..
See, this is another thing that I wanted about the game,
is like, the taking time to appreciate the environment
and taking time to actually see what's going on,
a-and that's what I was talking about when I was saying
that I was just blasting through things to get to
an objective. Which is perfectly fine
in normal circumstances,
but, i-in my gameplay, it made it so that it was altogether
less enjoyable. And that's not what I wanted out of it,
and now that I'm here, at night, in this beautiful--
--admittedly, very beautiful--
glowy, brilliant underground-- it's so cool--
Air bubbles!!! Bloof! "Bloof" in my face!
Auhhh... I got "bloofed" all over me... That's really cool...
Like, it's REALLY cool- it's terrifying, and it's dark now,
But it's really cool.
Ah geez... Oh gosh, I'm all alone down here...
Oh, I have no friends- All my friends are dead,
and that's another thing to remember,
ALL my friends are dead! I'm kinda down here alone- I don't know that--
AI Voice: Emergency, 10 seconds of oxygen remaining.
Mark: I mean, my character doesn't know that yet,
but you know.
It's a pretty dead--
Like pod number 5 and whatever the hell THAT is.
That looks bigger than it used to.
My gahd, can I get to the top of this bad boy?
At least I get a better vantage point of actually
being able to climb on top of the thing.
oh.. that's so cool!
OH, that's so cool, SCAN THAT!
SCAN IT! Scanning planet to find out more!
Hello, what the fuck are you?
OH! They finally replaced the moon!
So it's not earth's moon up there.
Gahd, they put a lot of stuff in here.
Oh cool, I've never even looked at the logs before.
AUGH!! What is THAT?!
Eughhh!!!
"A common scavenger at the base of the food chain."
"Threat Level: Minimum."
"Small enough to be of no threat, even to small organisms,"
"adapted to feed on the waste products
of the ecosystem."
"Used to orient themselves" and "Three
legs for high strength muscles."
Not harmful at all.
So, there must have been scouts out here,
I mean, that's where- that's what I was talking about.
There's abandoned bases out here,
and, I know I'm stalling, I'm not going out in the night
because I'm a big baby bitch, but anyway,
I need to make some more tools, and I need to make a knife, eventually.
Which means that I need silicon, and I need Creepvine...
seed clusters. So I'll go out and I'll get that in a bit.
That'll be the next thing that I do, and I'm
gonna do that, actually, right now.
I'm not gonna do that in a bit, I'm gonna
do it right now 'cause I'm a man...
A manly man....
That's me!
I'm a- I'm a big, strong man- Oh boy...
But I do need to empty my inventory
before I'm able to do that.
I got a lot of titanium here,
which I don't even know where I'm gonna pu- where the fuck am I gonna PUT it?!!
Where the fuck am I gonna put it?!
I don't have any storage!
Good gawd...
I don't even have a builder!
AUGH!! I have NOTHING!
I have NOTHING!!
NOTHING!!!
(Garbled Laughter-like noises)
Mark: Ah!! Don't laugh at me!!! -- Auh! I hate it!
AI Voice: Emergency: 10 seconds of oxygen remaining.
I hate it, I hate-- I hate this, I hate this!
Everything about this is terrible, and I haven't been able
to put all my shit anywhere because I can't put it in the--
(Character coughs)
Aw, I can't put it in the life-pod. Can I?
Maybe they changed that. Maybe I
can put it in the life-pod.
I guess I haven't tried, so I guess that's my bad.
Please tell me that's daylight coming--
Auh, it is, okay, it is, it is, we're doing good.
Maybe I can dump it all here...
Can I?
Please?
Ah--Ohhh....
I can't-- I can't dump it here.
Auh, I'm fucked.
*gasp* Storage container?!
Oh, thank you!
OH! FLARE!! WATER!!!
Nutrient block?!! YES!!!
I didn't even know that existed!
Oh, thank you!!!
I thought I was gonna have to dump it on the ground!
Oh, you're so helpful!
Well, THANK YOUUUU!!!
THANK YOUUUUU!!!!!!
Okay, now.. Now I can actually go. It's NOT night.
Oh fuck, man.
God, I forget how stressful this goddamn
game is when you're on your own!
I HATE THE OCEAN SO MUCH!
'Kay.. so.. alright, so I've got maximum
number of those that I can get..
So I did it! Hooray!!!
(Low, menacing, rumbling noise)
Mark: Okay, that better be Sancho, but, then again, it's been a while.
AI Voice: Emergency. 10 seconds of oxygen remaining.
It's been MONTHS since I played this, so all the sounds
are a little unfamiliar to me, so I'm not 100%
sure exactly what I'm doing here.
Why is that falling down from there?
Why is it getting dark so quickly?
What th-- AHHH!!! DANG NO!!!!
OH GAWD!!! AUGH!! Gawddammit!!!
AUH!!! FUCK, AHH Gahdammit!!!
(Dark, menacing music)
AUH, Nooo!!!!!!
NOOOOO!!!!!!
Auh, Gahddammit!!
I'm an idiot!!
Oh no... I'm so stupid!!!
I was like, "Why is it getting dark?"
"Is night here already?"
"That's weird."
"OH NO, Wait, I'm drowning."
'Cause I'm dumb
Okay. Let's try this again, and not die, again...
This time, I probably am gonna die....
Gahd, see? This is another thing that I'm not used to!
The reason I died there, is because, before,
I cheated, and skipped ahead, and farmed ahead,
and I had so much gahddamned stuff, that I was just
able to do everything that I wanted to do, and I didn't
have to worry about fuckin' AIR!!
(Ominous white noise)
Fuckin' hell...
Oh, you creepy bitch...
Whatever you is...
you're creepy as shit, and I don't like you!!
Until I get weapons, and build big things,
I don't like you.
I don't WANT to like you,
and I don't think I will EVER like you.
So I'm gonna go back, and then remember how much I don't like you.
I'm gonna make a knife.... Oh boy...
Yay!!!
I got a knife.
"Weapons were removed from the standard survival
blueprints following the massacre on Obraxis Prime.
As an essential survival tool for 2.5 million years,
the knife remains the only exception. Sorry about that."
WHAT?!!!
What does THAT mean?! 2.5 MILLION years?!
Oh, they're talking about all of human evolution.
That is just FASCINATING!
It's fascinating about the story of this game
and the story of the universe you're in.
Humanity is so far advanced, that-- It's reasonable to see
they're so far advanced because, number one,
they're making all of this insane bullshit,
like th- Stuff is just being fabricated
(Mark means  "created")
with LASERS!!! You're MAKING things!
WITH LASERS!!!!
And that's incredible by itself, but also,
Humanity, as a whole, has advanced so far,
that things like weapons are completely removed,
and everyone is just cool with that,
from standard colonization bullshit.
FINS! O2 TANK! YES! All things that I need!
I'm doing GREAT!
I'm a survivor who's used to not having.. bullshit like cheat codes!
Which I don't have anymore.
Okay, so I need table coral sample,
and then I need silver, and I think I'm good!
I think I'm going to be doing pretty good.
I don't know if I'm an- Am I faster?
Is this, is th- GARY! Am I faster?!
Do I seem faster to you?!!
Thanks Gary, you're always a help.
Okay, so there's silver down in the, uh... "Death Place",
you know, the "Death place." And thankfully, I've got a little more air here,
and there's that emergency stop for air if I need it.
But, we're just gonna venture down
and get the silver that we need,
while trying to avoid death in the shape of that monster.
And if I find other resources-- Whoa..
Seaglide fragment. HELL YES! YES!
YES!!!!!!!
But still, the mystery remains. Why... did our ship go down? Why?
Through standard atmospheric entry, through what can
only be standard procedure for these advanced humans,
in everything that they do,
and all the technology they have,
no one else survived.
Why did NO one survive?
In this day and age, when they probably have a bajillion safety protocols--
WHA-- FUCKING FUCK! Fuck.  I'll fight you.. bitch.
What are you? I was try- I was trying to look at thi...
UGH Fuck you! What the fuck was that?!
The fuck was that?! ... What the fuck was that?!
What the fuck?
Holy shit..
'Kay.. Got silver, finally.
So, sandstone and limestone are now definitively different--
Which is a thing--
I'm pretty sure what that was-- I think it said like,
"Primary directive is to swim towards [it]."
So, that thing... Controlled my MIND!
(Sancho sounds and creepy, demonic,
laughter-like sounds)
Auh.. What are YOU?!
What is with the noises?! Is it you? You?
What is tha- That's a new thing.
No, is that new? I have no idea.
There's so many different things!
I have no goddamn IDEA!!
Oh man, okay.
BUT, we got what we needed,
we did get what we need.
Actually, we did NOT get what we need, so I'm- Oh, hey-
Hey, how's it goin' there, buddy?
Sorry, I gotta put YOU away-- Ha-Buurshki--
Haaa-burshki, ha-bursh-, haa-burshki...
I need also stamboard corebell(?)
Can I scan you? Rabbit ray!
Eey! Rabbit Ray, come back here!
Where're you goin'?
I need some more coral...
COOOOOORAAL
Okay, ~HA-BU-DUH-BUUSHKII~
Let me just save, 'cause I haven't done that yet.
I don't need to lose all my progress that has been
HARD fought and not CHEATED FOR! So I need
to make-- Oooh, a "Dive Reel?"
Alright, that's fine... Don't know why I'd
need to be pulled back that quickly-- OH WAIT...
NO. That'd be GREAT for when I
dove down in that GIANT HOLE!!!
That would've been good to be pulled back from!
Ha, Ha, Ha, Ha, Ha. :) Now, I can make
THE HABITAT BUILDER!
Bada-BOOSKI! This is EXACTLY
what I needed... I now have the
Habitat builder, and
I will be able to do what I need to do
to build myself a home.
Eventually! With time,
because, as I expect,
it's night outside-- OOH, it's not, thank goodness...
It's not night yet... but
it's gonna be night soon, and I'm gonna be
wallowing around in death, for AGES and AGES..
and ages and ages. But either way,
welcome to a brand new beginning in Subnautica.
There's a lot of ocean to explore,
and what's even better,
is that I'm gonna be continually exploring, without even knowing
what's on the horizon.
So, THANK YOU, EVERYBODY, so much for watching!
Lemino what you think, and any other things you'd like to say to me down in the comments below.
I will be reading, and, hopefully in the next episode,
I will have lockers for with which you
(Unintelligible)
So thanks again, and as always,
I will see you...
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!!!
AI Voice: "Emergency: Seismic readings suggest a
Aw, fuck!
quantum detonation has occurred in the Aurora's drive
core. The central dark matter reactor will reach a super
critical state in T minus: 10... 9... 8...
Hey Peeper, you wanna see this? Bet you do.
AI Voice: 7... 6...
Stare your big eyeball right into the center of the dang thing.
AI Voice: 5... 4...... 3...
AI Voice: 2....."
*Ship explodes* *Darkiplier*
Ayyy-yup.
And as always, I'll see you...
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!!!
BUH-BYEE!!!
(outro music)